hey guys so the topic of the cheat mail
keeps coming up over and over and over
and over I wanted to create a video on
some other aspects of it so I have all
these points in one video okay so number
one when you're first starting keto and
you're not fully adapted into
fat-burning I don't recommend that you
cheat okay because it's going to take a
lot longer to get back on track
could take 20 hours or more just from
one meal because it takes a while to get
in ketosis but once you're fully adapted
after a few months you'll be able to
bounce back a lot quicker and of course
you make up the damage so that's one
thing and number two if you feel the
need to go off the program
ask yourself what problem am I trying to
solve and try to solve the deeper
problem whatever that is is it a blood
sugar problem is it something else
because a lot of times people cheat just
to feel better to bring their mood up
you know okay next point is once you
start it's really hard to stop I'll give
you my own example in my 20s I was
addicted to sugar in fact my whole life
that was addicted all the way up until I
hit probably 28 years old I was the guy
that would not be consistent I kept
cheating I kept eating junk and massive
quantities maybe I would try to go to
the grocery store and buy all these
healthy foods but then I would also buy
some junk food and eat that Doritos
pizza you name it and this went on for
many many years and through college so I
would eat something the blood Sugar's
spiked and then crashed and then I'd
want it the next day
okay so I was in this kind of this
little trap right here so realize once
you start it's hard to stop and it
really took me a long time before I can
actually stay consistent and do this a
hundred percent and I don't really need
to go off the program because I feel so
good on it and I also know how would
feel if I went off of it and it's just
not worth it and also the goal is to
build up enough health and your body
that you have so much reserve you know
going off the program occasionally is
not going to even create a
into your health at all but in the
beginning not good because you have to
create the health so if you're just
starting out and you're having
challenges it's okay to actually start
out and do the best you can and
gradually work up to 100% but just
realize we want to get to this hundred
percent eventually all right thanks for
watching
hey guys so I'm doing a survey of a
future video and I wanted to find out
what your biggest body problem is so
that way the content is aligning with
something that you are personally
interested in so please click the link
down below fill it out and I will create
the video thanks